mais là messieurs bonsoir neuf jours
après l'accident de la centrale
nucléaire de tchernobyl les soviétiques
ont pu voir à la télévision les
premières images de la centrale dans
leur journal de ce soir autre fait
nouveau après le grand silence
moscou a invité le directeur général de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique aiea geste qui a créé une
certaine surprise selon les propres mots
de l'inviter monsieur rase vic chante
alouette les téléspectateurs soviétiques
ont vu ce soir pour la première fois
depuis la catastrophe ces images de la
région de tchernobyl
accompagné d'un commentaire rassurant
images prises d'un hélicoptère qui a
survolé la centrale accidentée
regardez bien voici le bâtiment du
réacteur 4 et son toit éventré tel qu'on
l'avait déjà vu sur une photo noir et
blanc
ce même jour et pour la première fois
également depuis l'accident lurs ouvre
ses portes à des personnalités
étrangères
le directeur général de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
accompagné d'un expert américain de la
sécurité nucléaire est attendu lundi à
moscou
tu as fait encore état pour la première
fois de la présence du spécialiste
américain le docteur galles qui préside
une association internationale de greffe
de moelle osseuse
autant d'initiatives nouvelle qui
s'accompagne de protestation contre ceux
qui tentent d'exploiter écrit l'agent se
tassent sans nous les désigner davantage
ceux qui tentent d'exploiter l'accident
à des fins politiques at home